hi I'm Calvin Michaud from Wolfram
research and hi I'm Ashley brodnik from
wolf research our talk is a hands-on
start to Wolfram Alpha notebook edition
so we'll show a live look at the product
and talk about the spirit of the product
today we're going to talk about
WolframAlpha notebook edition and what
it is likely you have heard about this
product and that is why you're here
today maybe you are wondering why we
needed a new tool maybe you just wanted
to see what it looks like we'll cover
that too
and of course we'll tell you how to get
your hands on it so all of you know that
Mathematica is an expert software
calculation visualization and data
analysis capabilities that rivals any of
our competitors our team has done an
amazing job building natural language
programming for Wolfram Alpha but
unfortunately for the k-12 and community
college market there are some
limitations of those two things than
themselves so we needed to provide
something where the programming wasn't a
hurdle Wolf's language can be too hard
for some and using the Wolfram Alpha
notebook or sir I apologize Wolfram
Alpha website can be limiting because
you're just doing one off calculations
so we needed to marry the two
environments this way we can reach new
young inexperienced non-technical users
so Calvin what does this look like yeah
so we are breaking from format and
giving this presentation in the Wolfram
Alpha notebook edition so the first
thing I mean as Ashley mentioned it's
the best of notebooks and Wolfram Alpha
and it's got all the cool notebook
structure of course so you can make text
cells you can have explanation and you
can have live calculations all in the
same format so just as you can do this
in mathematic and Wolfram language you
can do this in notebook edition so
Steven talked about this a bit at the
keynote so I will try not to repeat what
he said but the workflow for Wolfram
Alpha notebook edition really points you
towards this everyday English way of
entering calculations it is that being
said it's all notebook so notebook is a
notebook but in terms of the workflow it
really encourages you to use this every
English to use the Wolfram Alpha
technology to turn plain everyday
English into something that is a
computation so here in this case we're
just simplifying an algebraic expression
and then also we can say something like
graph that so this is one big difference
between this having this in a local
notebook in a product versus the website
the website is very very useful but it's
very much a one-shot experience you go
there you do one calculation you do the
next one you do the next one there's not
really a good narrative or a good
history nor can it remember your last
calculation so this is one huge benefit
to the notebook Edition where when you
say graph that there's a notion of what
was my last calculation what was that
which is unique to this product and and
very very useful the other thing that's
built into the product is step by step
solutions so if you say derivative of
something there are these suggestion
bars here that are specific to this
product so when you click on this this
is going to start a new Wolfram Alpha
notebook input it's going to say show
the steps of this and then in terms of
checking your homework or working on
this as a learner there is the
recognition that the chain rule is good
for this you know it follows typical
textbook formats where it coaches you
through this sort of problem but if
you're learning this you can click the
one one at a time show steps to figure
out did you make an addition error do
you have it right do you not understand
the concept you should read the chapter
again so that show steps part of this
which is a big big part of the website
is also present here and works the same
way just as you can say graph that you
can define variables and functions as
well so you can say set a equals to five
five a equals ten and so here in this
case not only am i turning everyday
English into a computation but there is
the notion of it's remembering what a is
through this session
so if you're working on a problem and
defining things and exploring things bit
by bit by bit this whole concept is
really useful you can unset a and then
it goes back to a symbol where if we say
what is 5a plus then then it gives us a
as a symbol again so just as Wolfram
language notebooks have this notion of
calculations and the colonel's
remembering what's going on Wolfram
Alpha notebook Edition has this as well
where as you work through these projects
you can define things and undefined
things in the same way you can also
define functions so if I say set f of X
equal to x squared plus 5 and then I use
the derivative notation for that or work
with f of X you know the notion of f of
X is present in this as well so Stephen
showed some more general examples of
plotting and things like that
though the capabilities of this this is
all built on the same Wolfram language
just like Wolfram Alpha is so I'm
showing a few unique things here but
keep in mind that the plotting engine
the solving engine the derivatives
that's all the same engine that's in the
core Wolfram language so it's the power
of Mathematica with this easy interface
to enter calculations you can also graph
something where you say graph a certain
equation varying a from 1 to 5 and then
what that does is it creates a
manipulate so when you say vary a from 1
to 5 really what you're looking for is
varying an input and looking at a
pattern so you're building a model here
where you explore some some property of
this equation or some property of
something and it's very nice that this
this sort of everyday English is
understood as well you can work with 3d
graphics and this is not a talk on the
Wolfram Alpha parser but you know the
Wolfram Alpha parser has a lot of
experience with understanding what we
mean when we say x and y you know in
this case we're talking about a surface
block
because we're treating those as
variables but the idea of short cutting
a lot of these things where as as a
learner or as a student or as someone
just doing everyday computation however
you state some sort of calculation or
graphic or or whatever whatever everyday
English you use for that the goal is
that that works and that the parser
handles that very nicely you can also do
special characters I'm in the notebook
presentation here but if you end this
and go to a new notebook so there's a
button for special characters again
similar to the pro version of
wolframalpha.com
where you have the common things you
need like PI and like infinity and
square roots and things so to use that
in the notebook here go back to full
screen so we can say PI to a hundred
digits and calculate that or we can
calculate something like a limit but
instead of using X or a or something
like that we can use you know special
characters and infinity and things like
that and all these things work very very
well so in addition to this and
supporting this
we are planning a reference text which
I'll show just a little bit of so myself
and Michael Morrison and cliff Hastings
who is sitting here you might know that
we have a reference text for Wolfram
language where let me go to the first
part of this so we have the hands-on
start to wolfram mathematica textbook
where it's a slow build of complexity
it's meant for novice users it's not
specific to any field it's just a very
good general resource this is the view
of the Wolfram language book we are
planning a book for Wolfram Alpha
notebook edition as well where this will
be a nice reference this chapter follows
the other book where it's a sample
project
we feel like this is a useful thing just
to understand the bounds of the project
so something where you might want to
query some data what's the minimum wage
in Massachusetts or query some dates
this particular case is a project where
it's a student who's was working a
summer job and trying to figure out how
much did they work and how much time can
they take off so asking a real world
world question like if I could only work
Monday through Friday what's the next
Monday after May 21st 2019 that's a very
relevant question but this first chapter
is designed to be a sample project that
shows things like working with dates or
working with units or some parses like
make a graph of a line connecting to
specific points and then we get a nice
graph there with the points as well so
the supporting text is something that
we're planning and we feel like that
this this will be like the last book
where it will be a good reference text
it'll give people ideas and also
probably a jumping-off point to then
make your own materials okay and then
Ashley is going to talk about
availability and how we're rolling out
this product and how you can get it so
the initial release of wolf Rafah
notebook addition is desktop only but
the cloud is in development now and in
the not-too-distant future
we were released a hybrid version that
has desktop and cloud access and for
those of you that are Mathematica users
in the next release of Mathematica the
ability to create these special
notebooks these WolframAlpha notebooks
will be built into your Mathematica so
the product is Wolfram Alpha notebook
Edition the capability to create those
notebooks will be a part of your
Mathematica version in the next release
so today you can get version 1 it is
available on our web store it is as you
can kind of gather from Kelvin in my
talk today a pre-college focused product
so we're looking at professors high
school teachers students as well as home
hobbyist this is not intended to be
a commercial product especially for the
initial release what about at your
organization well many of you come to us
from site licensed schools so we have
models where you can have full faculty
staff student access to our technologies
so we have a plan to roll this in so
that you can add this to an existing
site license that you have you can start
a new site license so maybe you come
from a school who only has limited
access to Mathematica but this is the
thing that would get widespread access
and use of our technology we can start a
Wolfram Alpha notebook edition site
license at your school maybe you are a
four-year professor so you're at one of
those first group you have that big site
license but you also do some adjunct
work at a community college and that
Community College has no access to our
type of technology you could start a
site license of wolf ralph a notebook
addition at that Community College where
as you're using Mathematica back at your
quote home base or your four-year and
then of course we offer bundles so maybe
it's wolf Rafa Pro and wolf off a
notebook edition or it's one of those
subscription models and if you're super
motivated today there are some steps
that you can take so number one go to
our web store you can buy Wolfram Alpha
Notebook addition students subscriptions
for your children there's probably
students right you can register those
licenses in their names if you're a home
hobbyist you could buy your own
subscription and register in your name
of course if you're a Mathematica user
make sure you have active service
because as I said when we released the
next version of Mathematica you'll have
this notebook capability in it and
you'll get that for free as the benefit
of your service if you are in that group
where your site license group is rather
you're a faculty member out of state
license school and you're wondering
about what this looks like at your
individual campus and how do I get this
added or who do I lobby to just email me
I can be your direct point of contact
for that and then lastly Kelvin and I
are running a hands-on workshop right
after this so
stay in your seat and have some
first-hand experience look at that we
have extra time and we obviously have
flexibility cuz we have the next lock
too so some questions yes yeah so that's
probably something I should have touched
on more which is this is also acts as a
tutor for Wolfram language so just as in
the wolframalpha.com website you can
click and get that pod that shows the
Wolfram language you can hopefully in
presentation mode go in here and once
you start typing it it goes from well
that wasn't a very big change was it
okay cosine or something okay so when
you start to type in here it goes from
gray to black and then you can start
typing it so I think the initial I mean
the initial use of it is very driven
towards starting with everyday English
but yes that's a big part of it where
once you start to see square brackets
and things like that then people very
well might just start to usable from
language when they I mean there's a
there's a limit to what the parser can
do obviously there's always the next
customization that you want to do that
old form alpha can't quite keep up with
so when you hit that point the language
is there and it's it starts to tutor you
thank you that's a good question visit
this there's these high school students
then become college students and the
more introduction that they've had to
our technology the more prepared they
are for that more advanced use and those
students obviously then become our
future commercial and academic users as
well so there's there's that continuum
that some are starting with Wolfram
Alpha notebook edition and eventually
moving to Mathematica as they grow and
advance in their careers and others this
is the product for them you know as I
mentioned those young and experienced or
non techie people the non tech people
might just want to have access
our capabilities and not ever want to
dive into the code yes yeah good
question there are several options I
don't know the entire full rubric but
the % works so if you're a Wolfram
language user I think I have to go back
a couple those this one okay yeah so
what you said literally I think was
graph above which works there are
probably more like a dozen things that
work not hundreds of things but
hopefully we've chosen the smart ones
where we're one for one here with your
suggestions which is good which which
would you so if you say I mean if you
say this so it yes okay yeah yeah
Richard
yes good question I don't think either
of us know a lot about the pre-release
program but talk to us after and we'll
make sure you talk to the right person I
think okay thank you yeah
okay and getting back to your first
question - I the spirit of this is a
group to reach a new group not to
replace not to move people from one
product to the other and I think I
personally will still use the website I
still use the app I still want to do
that one off calculation I think that
workflow will still be useful it being
on the web is useful in and of itself
the benefit here is if you want to take
that next step
integrate it into your course and really
have some guided courseware where it's
not just the student going off and doing
whatever and you have no idea what
they're doing but you're really guiding
what they're doing that that's the
that's the the void we're trying to fill
so to speak
yeah
so similar to it this I mean you would
have to make those same decisions with
Mathematica the decisions would be
similar to Wolfram Alpha notebook
edition I don't know a ton about I think
you can probably save it to PDF or print
it I'm not totally sure that that's
exactly accurate but I mean people could
print it out
well we intend though is the product is
subscription-based and that the
instructor and the students would all
have their own subscriptions and when
they save their finished project as a
notebook then they would somehow turn it
in then a dot notebook right yes it
would be yes yeah but the and the
question you're asking is a really good
one so when we have the browser-based
version of this then we can piggyback
more on the publishing and sharing
infrastructure of the cloud where
instead of trying to email files or
manage files or is the file too big that
whole infrastructure of sending around
URLs which is much much easier then that
will apply to this as well so when we
have the browser-based version that
whole running a class will go from good
to really really good sorry wait cliff
yeah yeah that's a good question and I
mean a notebook is a notebook so
although this will exist in 12.1 in
Mathematica you know there's a certain
if you have to explain too much that's
never a good thing so if you're teaching
a college algebra class and you have to
say okay go to this other mode and
disregard this and don't do the language
and and do this it is easier to have
this sort of separate environment that
really makes this foolproof where
students will use this however that
being said if the students have
WolframAlpha notebook Edition and they
send you a notebook and you open it in
Mathematica in 12.1 it will look the
same so there is we're not we're not
taking things away in WolframAlpha
notebook edition we're more guiding you
to that workflow so that when you're
authoring things and starting things you
start with the everyday English but the
interchange between the two especially
after twelve one is released but it
seems to work okay now doesn't it cliff
yeah it seems to work okay now but
twelve one it will work better thank you
mmm that's a good question I don't know
the answer to that
I would imagine programming lab no
desktop I don't know yes clean yes yes
okay is the what do you do you think
about the programming lab okay no on
programming lab yes and wolfram desktop
[Music]
we can give you five more minutes
yeah
but thank you everyone for coming
[Applause]